avec désormais même un petit jingle pour
pour vous Véronique puisque vous nous
présentez chaque semaine vos insolites
c'est le mardi sur TV 78 des
informations qui sortent de l'ordinaire
et qui méritent toute notre attention
alors décidément les stars du cinéma
aiment venir dans les Yvelines puisque
vous nous parlez la semaine dernière
d'une avant-première la venue
d'Alexandre à Lamy cette semaine c'est
Philippe Lachaud ça bande à Fifi qui
vient présenter son prochain film voilà
alors ils seront donc à Vélizy LGC le
mardi 7 février 20h45 la séance avec une
rencontre il rencontreront le public
après la projection la bande à Fifi vous
la connaissez ils sont originaires des
Yvelines il y a notamment le film
baby-sitting baby-sitter
Paris à tout prix mais visiting 2 et là
justement on a alibi.com 2 donc la bande
sera là Philippe Lachaud Elodie Fontan
Tareg Boudali Julien routier voilà et
c'est un film évidemment plein de gags
réjouissants jubilatoire il y aura dans
la dans la
Gérard Jugnot Nathalie Baye Arielle
Dombasle et Didier
quelques petits secrets qu'ils auront
ben on va essayer bien sûr ouais ça
donne envie dans un style différent
différents on peut le dire en 5e édition
du festival des langues classiques qui
se déroulent vendredi et samedi à
Versailles alors dis comme ça ça peut
faire un peu peur moi je garde un assez
mauvais souvenirs de mes cours de latin
personnellement au collège mais
donnez-nous envie c'est quoi ce festival
c'est très varié il y a plein de choses
il y a des rencontres des ateliers et
des films des conférences ce sont donc
des langues anciennes oh mais vraiment
cinquième édition chinois latin grec
vous aurez donc trois lieux le tel de
ville le l'Université Ouverte et le
l'UGC Roxane vous avez un programme très
chargé il faut regarder sur le le site
de la mairie vous avez par exemple Denis
modelydès l'acteur de la Comédie
Française Versailles a d'ailleurs qui
vient faire une lecture sur les animaux
fantastiques de la littérature grecque
vous avez aussi
je vous donne quelques exemples mais il
y a plein de choses les bestiaires de
l'antiquité une conférence avec Michel
pastoraux Michel pastoraux San historien
qui est spécialiste des couleurs des
symboles et des animaux car ce que je
n'ai pas dit décidément c'est que le
thème cette année c'était des animaux et
des hommes voilà et pour un autre
exemple pour terminer un atelier origami
avec 12 animaux de la mythologie
chinoise le samedi 4 je vous ai inscrit
Grégory l'inscription est faite ça
s'annonce passionnant
avec vos enfants ados franchement c'est
pas que sérieux et savant c'est aussi
ludique et ça va peut-être déclencher
des des vocations d'hélénistes de la
tennis
Véronique avec l'ouverture d'un café
joyeux c'est au centre commercial Parly
2 au généraux-cancourt c'est quoi un
café joyeux est-ce qu'on peut rappeler
déjà alors un café joyeux c'est un
concept en fait ce sont des cafés dans
lesquels vous trouvez 80% des employés
qui sont soit porteurs de d'un syndrome
autistique soit porteur de trisomie 21
donc ça ça fait partie du l'essentiel du
personnel qui sont encadrés par des
managers qui sont donc formés à ce genre
de personnes un peu atypiques et donc
l'idée c'est de créer du du lien de les
inclure dans la société de leur donner
un travail un salaire de l'autonomie de
la confiance en soi et donc ça s'appelle
le café joyeux il y en a plusieurs en
France il y en a à Lisbonne à Bruxelles
qui a une dizaine en France et donc
celui-ci vient d'ouvrir à parler de son
commercial
port-saint-michel plus précisément donc
vous pouvez y aller évidemment prendre
un café vous pouvez y aller déjeuner les
cuisiner et faites sur place des
produits frais de saison les menus
changent toutes les semaines vous avez
aussi un menu végétarien
et quoi dire d'autre et bien et bien
info sur ce sujet
il y en a plein dans le monde et c'est
le premier il faut savoir que un
souvenir c'est que avant le covid ce
projet était déjà sur la table parce que
ils envisagé d'ouvrir justement un café
joyeux à Versailles et donc bon il est
ouvert aujourd'hui à Paris 2 mais c'est
un projet qui date d'avant le covid-19
avant 2020 bientôt à Versailles non le
projet donc je pense que voilà c'est
celui-là mais donc la réflexion était
déjà en cours déjà avant le comité se
trouve juste intéressant à suivre c'est
que franchement le centre commercial par
les deux c'est un peu le temple de la
consommation du paraître et là au cœur
de cet endroit il va y avoir il va y
avoir du cœur justement de l'humain de
la chaleur humaine et et un lieu qui a
vraiment du sens humainement parlant une
initiative merci Véronique bien sûr
mardi prochain
informations vous avez parlé en plus de
nourriture sur la fin ça nous a donné
faim c'est d'ailleurs bientôt l'heure de
passer à table